but by the way i want to mention it this
new movie you have
yeah emily the criminal i watched it now
listen when they when your publicist was
like here's the link you want to watch
the movie i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't have
time to watch a [ __ ] movie right now
what the [ __ ] and i just started it i
played it while i was looking at some
emails i'm being honest with you and i
was sucked the [ __ ] in
i was sucked in it's so intense and
aubry plaza is brilliant and you're
brilliant in it and it's such a just
this crazy relationship that happens
between the two of you
and
the movie is just like you feel for i
like movies when you feel for the lead
character who's doing the wrong thing
but you understand why she's doing it
and it's just this weird journey that i
was honestly at times like in the room i
won't say give anything away with the
clock ticking and in the beginning i'm
just like oh my god and those characters
you're just like it's kind of it's a
heist movie it's it's it's much more
than that but i was really impressed
with this and people could watch emily
the criminal where everywhere
everywhere 10 theaters everywhere yeah
aubrey and i uh were just together we
did our two premieres in la and new york
we were both kind of flying from other
jobs in and we got seen on the big
screen because we debuted sundance but
sundance went virtual
uh last year
and really cool we were the highest
rated film out of sundance you know it
was this little movie that you know
i mean we shot in 21 days that we just
didn't
not that we didn't expect anything aubry
produced it it was kind of this thing
that i was doing this other movie in
atlanta and her and i zoomed and it was
like yeah like i when when i see because
i produce some stuff like when i see
someone putting it all out there and i
read the script it's a 90-minute movie
you know it's a fast read on the script
and
i like movies that i call like
replacement theory like where i can
watch it and go what would i do if i was
that person what would i do if i was in
that situation those are my favorite
movies like the game with michael
douglas oh yeah yeah yeah you know what
would happen here and it's
when i watch films and i read films like
that i'm like
that's what i want to do i want to i
want to go on that ride it's like a six
flags ride and
her and i just you know when it debuted
sundance it had a ton of buzz you know
like i said highest rated one we were
just waiting for it to come out
roadside's amazing um we're in like i
think we're in like 500 theaters now
across the country which is really cool
um it did really well it's the highest
critical thing i've ever been a part of
um
in all ways she's extraordinary in it
yeah
both you guys
yeah and you just want people you know
john patton ford first time director
um great job
yeah just amazing so
it's been a really cool like run the
last few years and i feel like this was
the one that i was
i'm really excited about this one
because it's again a wildly different
character than i've been playing yeah
you guys have to see it emily the
criminal i mean it really is good trust
me i was if you could write into me you
could write on the patreon yeah and you
could tell me what an [ __ ] i am but
you're i'm not wrong on this one this
was a movie that i was just emailing
while i'm listening and watching and
then i just got sucked in i'm telling
you and there was no turning back it was
just great performances intensity uh
just a really good story and you care
about the characters which is which is
hard to do
yeah i mean you know it's that anti-hero
thing we've been doing since like you
know uh uh vic mackie and the shield and
you know obviously a bunch of things
where you start to like the villain i
think we've probably been doing it a lot
longer than that it's just been you know
kind of more uh uh amplified with
television yeah right you know speaking
of so we were just talking about this
the other day my buddy and i it's like
and you you know you obviously taking on
one of the most legendary characters in
history and lex luthor but i talked
about gene hackman and when he played
lex luthor it's like i liked him way
more than superman when i was a kid i
knew it yeah
i don't know why i just did
like him better he was better to watch
yeah right
that's not supposed to happen but then
if you look at the godfather and stuff
like that we identify more where we go
oh
because they're you know they're i'm
probably going to say the word wrong but
they're they're fallible yeah they're
where would with superheroes or good
characters i don't mean in the literal
sense of the cape when you're the good
character the the straight you know lace
you can't
have anything wrong with you
where
the the one who's a little
uh
ambiguous has more things going on
there's and that's life we're all
you know the yin and the yang of life so
so i think that with emily
that's the service of what john created
where you go
i know these people are doing something
wrong but i gotta tell you i kind of
like him i know it's just so weird when
that happens it's a little magic